I really really like being
pregnant Beth Anderson is a married
mother of two and twice a surrogate she
not only loves being pregnant but loves
helping out families to be by carrying a
donated egg to term for them mosts
develop a relationship with their
parents um and have continued contact
afterwards stories like beths are
becoming more common the American
Society of Reproductive Medicine found
gestational surrogate Birds more than
doubled in the last 10 years with each
surrogate making around 20,000 to
$335,000 while the medical field has
advanced the ease and safety of
surrogacy State policy has lagged behind
since the baby M case in 1986 surrogate
Mary Beth Whitehead and intended parents
William and Elizabeth Stern battled for
child custody in and out of court at the
heart of the problem Whitehead and the
Sterns did what's known as traditional
surrogacy using Whitehead's own egg and
creating a legal headache for State
policy makers New York was one one of
the states that after the infamous Baby
M case moved to Outlaw surrogacy
altogether and that has existed ever
since Brad Hilman is a New York state
senator working on passing a bill that
will secure paid contracts for
surrogates in the state what it does is
legalize gestational surrogacy which is
a
technology uh whereby the egg is
fertilized outside of the womb and
implanted in a thirdparty carrier we can
actually have surrogates carry children
who are not genetically related to them
the child's parent Security Act passes
in New York we'll have uh surrogates who
could actually uh engage um with
intended parents and egg donors and uh
create families since the surrogate
isn't genetically related to the baby
like the baby M case the woman simply
carries the child to term but the
exchange of money for pregnancy still
worries many we don't want to turn
procreation baby making into a Commerce
industry Jennifer La is president of the
center for bioethics and culture and
producer of several documentaries on
what she calls the commercial
exploitation driving surrogacy if you're
looking at the women who are doing this
for pay um not the altruistic you know
and I think the altruistic side of of
this equation is very slim cuz how many
women are going to really you know give
their body their whole body for 9 months
of a pregnancy um so but when you're
looking at the women who are actually
being paid uh and compensated for this
it's a class issue I mean you look at
Hollywood I mean it's the celebrities
are hiring suret you don't ever see the
celebrities offering to be the suret I
considered a symbiotic relationship you
know they need they need help this is
something that I want to do and it's a
way for me to make a little bit of extra
money that has helped with our savings
it you know it helped pay for this house
it's and which are things that would not
have been impossible without it for L
pregnancy is too complicated for
contracts to work this isn't just
entering into a contract cuz I have a
car and you want to buy a car and I have
a car to sell this is a human being this
is a new life um so I think you know
we're we're naive and thinking that um
this is just we can iron all this out as
adults and have contracts and anticipate
every problem um cuz that that isn't
really how the real world happens la
isn't wrong that contracts aren't
perfect but it's the way states make
surrogacy contracts difficult that is
the main cause of problems Virginia is a
right to life state so if the surate
delivers in Virginia the surate has 30
days to claim the kid as hers so because
she B she delivered for the state of
Virginia she is the mother Dr sherar is
founder and director of the Virginia
Center for Reproductive Medicine while
his practic he surrogates from all over
the country they must deliver in a state
friendly to surrogacy contracts any
couple who's looking into surrogacy
knows that there are very strong laws
that are out there that will protect
them and will protect the surrogate we
don't want the surrogate to steal their
baby and we don't want anyone to
actually abuse The Sur good so the legal
framework is there to protect the
parties and this is very critical we
really haven't studied um the impact on
families I was a pediatric nurse for 20
years um I've seen and interviewed
surrogates who had little children in
the home and the impact on little
children when they see their moms having
babies and giving them away what is the
impact on little children that are so
Concrete in their thinking that wonder
wow when will Mom give me away to a nice
lady who needs a baby um or why is Mommy
giving away my brother or sister it's
all in the way that you that you phrase
things it's all in the way that you put
it you know my children knew from you
know day one from the day I filled out
applications for agencies you know this
was something we talked about with the
second time around you know my kids were
old enough that you know we actually sat
down before we did it and said you know
we're thinking about helping another
Mommy and Daddy what are your thoughts
and they said that's fine and then ran
off and played you know um it's not
something that that they care about you
know I mean they're they're very
invested in in the pregnancy once you
start showing and and that kind of stuff
but all that other nonsense they're like
oblivious to and as same-sex marriages
become more common new demand for
families will will push the surrogacy
debate further Brad Hilman believes his
bill will give parents to be in New York
the same joy as his daughter gives him
my husband and I uh after getting
married decided we wanted to start a
family we did research on the issue and
found out that California is one of
those states where the law is very clear
uh where we could um find a surrogate uh
enter into a contract with her and an
egg donor and begin the process my
daughter's only three and a half uh
she's as happy and bright and funny and
mischievous as any three and a half ye-
old I know for people suffering from
infertility surrogacy is their last hope
for me this would be an area where I
would say if you can't have a child um
then then pursue you know other other
avenues women want to experience having
their own children and it's only after a
lot of had a lot of heartaches that they
and that they finally agree that maybe
the only way moving forward is to use
[Music]
services